last year one running back went in round
one the very last pick to the kansas
city chiefs peter king has two this year
projected one at 24
to the pittsburgh steelers alabama's
najee harris and then at number 30
travis atn the clemson running back to
the buffalo bills hey peter i've been
saying for weeks the steelers needed
frank o'haras he was the 13th overall
pick in 72 he came in right away he was
great from the get-go made the
immaculate reception to cap a historic
rookie season they need something like
that to balance out their offense and if
they're going all in this year with ben
roethlisberger at quarterback they need
a high-end running back to move the
chains and and not put pressure on that
passing game to constantly throw throw
throw like they did last year so i like
it i like it my my only concern is they
may not think any of these running backs
is worthy of a first-round pick but you
know what if you want to address that
need you don't want to wait till round
two go ahead get him taken maybe they
could trade down a few spots and still
get him but i just think they they have
to make it a priority
you know as their season was going up in
flames late in the season last year
uh and and this isn't exactly apples
tables but it's seven of their last 11
games last year including the playoff
game and they they rush for less than 55
yards
and everybody knows that they were a
horrible running team last year and the
logic says okay well let's get better on
the offensive front and that's that's
good logic
but
nancy harris
i think really really fits what they
want to do
because
he is a very good receiver out of the
backfield he'll give him a little bit of
what they had with le'veon bell and he's
a punishing runner who also can get
outside i'm not a fan of taking running
backs in the first round not at all
but
in in the exact
way that the steelers
conduct their business that every year
is a playoff year every year they're
going to try to win a lombardi this guy
is the best player for them this year at
this time
i i wondered how long it was going to
take me to stare at the name nadjay
harris
to realize franco harris najee harris
would they start calling him franco from
the moment he shows up in pittsburgh
regardless
that's what they need in pittsburgh if
they want to be as good as they can be
this year i'm also intrigued by the
bills travis atn brandon bean the gm
mentioned last week they need a home run
hitter at the position they thought zack
moss would balance out devin singletary
it still feels like they're missing
something peter in that running game
and when you look at the bills and yeah
they have some needs defensively but
that offense is so good the thing
they're missing is the running game and
a guy like travis atn could maybe help
them go next level they've got their
andre reid they've got their jim kelly i
said a couple of weeks ago they need
their thurman thomas and maybe atn could
be that
[Music]
hey look he scored 78 touchdowns
in four years at clemson now clemson
doesn't have the toughest schedule in
college football but it's clemson it's
major college
and and i think that the other thing
about
travis etienne that really has scouts
excited is he's a home run hitter not
only as a runner but out of the
backfield as a receiver too
22
plays of 40 yards or more and so to me i
think he is a guy who can be that great
jet sweep guy out of the backfield for
josh allen
and look at that look at that graphic
the first round draft picks at running
back since 2016. not on that list
because they weren't first-round picks
guys like dalvin cook
derrick henry
alvin camaro alvin commander
james robinson who wasn't even drafted
last year so many good running backs
that can be found at every round of the
draft and and if you're gonna go all in
with a first round draft pick on a
running back you better be able to make
him the guy right away three down guy
no platoon
no no load management you got to get him
on the field and you got to use him to
justify that pick peter
the one thing about the bills is that
this the first time you've been able to
say this in more than a generation
they can make a luxury pick in the first
round of the draft and that is what
travis at the end would be
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports